I always wanted to be a cartoonist I
don't want to be a cartoonist when I was
like you know third grade or something I
don't want to say exactly there's
something like that just comes out of me
like I have to do it but it is sort of a
compulsion I guess do you think that I
would have to answer that question by
now I think my cartoon because I think
now in terms of gag cartoons not in
terms of really complex narratives or
storylines but storylines that take four
seconds to understand well had nothing
much else I think I have a knack for it
I realize people get away with worse
than this so well so what I went yeah
what briefly to the School of Visual
Arts for something and I remember
meeting some guy he was learning some
sort of illustration we're talking about
the fact that he did a drawing for an
and I don't know what it was a teapot or
something he said it made me draw a
teapot I had to do it but it came out
pretty good it was really a nice teapot
and I thought well I hope I don't ever
have to do a nice teapot
listen to the facts the numerical
percentages are that you get published
or you can sell 1 out of 100 cartoons
maybe they're a 65 or 75 cartoonists in
the whole world you know like really
doing the single panel stuff single
panel talking and they're competing for
what even now even smaller number of
spots and your cartoon soul over my
cartoon to get that space you're taking
my space away but I love you just as
much I think you're terrific
now you admire you yeah wonderful and
maybe that's why we're all together to
have a lot